How we pick a target client
here at Dirty Didrini.
This is Adam.
I'm sitting down with him.
He's our Google ads guy
and our website guy.
He's putting together our website
for the paul's Bow location.
And using a specific demographic to pick that at
get that demographic from EZRI,
the most powerful demographic software in the world.
One of the first reports I'm going to look at
is the household income report.
That's going to tell me
what kind of money is in the area and how old it is.
After that, I'm looking at Automotive
Aftermarket Expenditures report
to find out if they're spending money on their vehicles.
Then I reviewed a demographic
and income comparison profile
to find out where the money's going,
how old the money is,
and why it's going
the direction of this going.
Then we look at the market profile
to find out where people work,
why they work there,
what kind of college education they had,
what kind of education they have in general.
Discover people are spending money on entertainment,
shelter, and travel.
When I'm done,
I conclude that my demographic profile is 15:25,
making 99 to $200,000 per year,
with some college to graduate experience.
That likes designer clothing,
shows and fun,
enjoys traveling by plane,
and has a housekeeper.